[Music]
my music is the fusion of information
architecture and classical music the way
that you problem-solve
into in the world of technology in the
way that you problem-solve when your
information architect really lends
itself to problem-solving with the kind
of music that I do I attack those pieces
the same way that I might attack like a
project plan sort of you know going from
making a little prototype like I make
little song prototypes where I test an
idea and then I you know build more
functionality into it until eventually I
have an entire piece of music and then I
have to try to do everything I can to
make it function and make it scalable so
that it can bring it on to work
[Music]
when I construct a piece it's made up of
these little small building blocks and
you have to organize them into a piece
of music like a piece of information
with metadata the same thing is true for
like a musical phrase I really like to
be able to pick out every single little
sound and you can say oh yeah that's a
plug or oh that's a tap or that's a
harmonic and it's really neat when you
build up all these little small things
that you can make something that is like
otherworldly the current setup I have
right now is I have just a MacBook Pro
and all of my looping software is run on
the computer using Ableton Live and
super looper and some little what I call
a MIDI duct tape to hold it together
which is just some nasty Apple scripts
that allow me to control the whole thing
with my feet one of my goals is to never
touch the computer with my hands and I
don't want the computer to be a part of
the performance it's just a pencil I
don't actually write any music down I
started out trying to write it for
sixteen cellists and I had some fantasy
that I was going to get sixteen cellist
and they were going to come over to the
warehouse and we were all going to just
play this music it didn't quite go as
planned
everything I do is based on like the
limitations of technology I would say
recently they can do a lot and I'm sort
of dealing with the repercussions of
what it means to be able to do almost
anything which is a new problem for me